but there were other cops
who saw the honor in partnering with the community,
who saw the responsibility from themselves
to be able to work as partners with community leaders and faith leaders
in order to reduce violence in the community.
Same with probation officers,
same with judges,
same with folks who were up that law enforcement chain,
because they realized, like we did,
that we'll never arrest ourselves out of this situation,
that there will not be enough prosecutions made,
and you cannot fill these jails up enough
in order to alleviate the problem.
I helped to start an organization
20 years ago, a faith-based organization, to deal with this issue.
I left it about four years ago
and started working in cities across the United States,
19 in total,
and what I found out was that in those cities,
there was always this component of community leaders
who put their heads down and their nose to the grindstone,
who checked their egos at the door
and saw the whole as greater than the sum of its parts,
and came together and found ways to work with youth out on the streets,
that the solution is not more cops,
but the solution is mining the assets that are there in the community,
to have a strong community component
in the collaboration around violence reduction.
Now, there is a movement in the United States
of young people who I am very proud of who are dealing with the structural issues
that need to change if we're going to be a better society.
But there is this political ploy to try to pit police brutality
and police misconduct against black-on-black violence.
But it's a fiction.
It's all connected.
When you think about decades of failed housing policies
and poor educational structures,
when you think about persistent unemployment
and underemployment in a community,
when you think about poor healthcare,
and then you throw drugs into the mix
and duffel bags full of guns,
little wonder that you would see this culture of violence emerge.
And then the response that comes from the state is more cops
and more suppression of hot spots.
It's all connected,
and one of the wonderful things that we've been able to do
is to be able to show the value of partnering together --
community, law enforcement, private sector, the city --
in order to reduce violence.
You have to value that community component.
I believe that we can end the era of violence in our cities.
I believe that it is possible and that people are doing it even now.
But I need your help.
It can't just come from folks who are burning themselves out
in the community.
They need support. They need help.
Go back to your city.
Find those people.
"You need some help? I'll help you out."
Find those people. They're there.
Bring them together with law enforcement, the private sector, and the city,
with the one aim of reducing violence,
but make sure that that community component is strong.
Because the old adage that comes from Burundi is right:
that you do for me, without me, you do to me.
God bless you. Thank you.
(Applause)